and you have really arrived in the family
when you are given the secret of
how the Underberg is
mixed, that is Jaag's guard, like
the Coca-Cola formula. I would now
say that with Coca-Cola, I do
n't know exactly  to stand
up for the fact that it is like that. I got it
from my mother-in-law because my
father-in-law had already died
and my husband was doing other things, so
he came every now and then and then I
did that for a lot of time and that
is now part of the focus on ruertine
keep the recipe for the clergy
that no no we do it by hand
oh they have to they would have fun we look
like we come from somewhere else that's
not a clean job
craftsmen they have mix they mix
it themselves by hand of course oh okay a
okay yes  I told you we are craftsmen,
but they sell
millions of liters one-to-one and
yet five people are the ones
who make the mixture
correctly